there are lots of people in this area
and you know data science is just
exploding in all kinds of ways and I
think a lot of people are definitely
Millennials or people younger than
millenials are also looking you know it
seems like the values are shifting a
little bit where it's less about just
making money so I think initially
everyone's kind of like Oh data science
that's a lucrative field I can get a job
at you know getting more people to click
on ads or work get a job in finance
which it just told are totally fine jobs
they're kind of bored of studying you
know they get there and they like data
science but they're kind of bored of
getting people to click on ads and
they're you know they feel kind of
unfulfilled and lacking purpose and I
think there are ways to use this data
towards social good as well
Seth hi man how are you doing you're
good how are ya
yeah very good thank you I'm excited for
today big dater and all this sort of
stuff it's gonna be cool yeah observe
looking forward to it so first things
first how do you describe what you do
for work or on a day to day basis uh
well so I guess I'm I guess I'm a data
scientist and an author or writer so you
know I spend most my time on books I
wrote everybody lies I'm trying to write
I'm in the process of writing another
book and other than that I don't know a
lot of random projects they do random
consulting for companies and there's not
necessarily a standard day but I got you
is it a lot of time on spreadsheets so
similar sort of applications yeah are
the coding language there's a lot of
time with that kind of moving back and
forth between R and Google Docs because
I guess the combination of data science
which is all are in writing which is
Google Docs Joe yeah and then sometimes
just researching a lot of like reading
so a lot of reading other people study
is kind of reading what other people are
talking about since I can't just write
about my own studies which is a shame
yeah yeah lovely
so you wrote book codes
everybody lies New York Times bestseller
but I heard that you wanted to call it
how big is my penis is that right that
is correct yeah I wanted to call your
book how big is your penis now how big
is my opinion how big is my penis yes no
basically the reason for it is that
that's one at the top well I talked
about how many asks more Google more
questions about their penis than any
other body part and then one of the top
questions they asked Google about the
penis is how big is my penis which is
just like an absurd question to ask
Google they're not gonna do that I kind
of thought that that title would kind of
get the flavor what some of some of the
things I was talking about that kind of
but I think one of the things that my
research has shown is the absurdity of
the human condition the absurdity of
people we kind of people kind of put on
a very presentable front
but in the privacy of your own home on
their Google search engine or the
websites they visit and they go to
pornhub they kind of just show a
different side of themselves which is a
little bit stupid are a little bit less
polished a little bit weirder a little
bit sometimes nastier but I think it's
kind of it's kind of an a drifting view
of people that we haven't really it's
they had hmm yeah the totally unfettered
view why you you don't think that anyone
else who's watching but the data
analysts are watching you are well the
data analyzes all anonymous and
aggregate so I don't know that any
particular man searched how big is my
penis I just know that lots of Medicare
[Laughter]
you know what I think I think there is
an opening in the market for an app
which can use a are like augmented
reality you hold it up to your face you
angle the penis and then it it works out
I read it well how would you have to
know how big the face is all right you
need like something behind you need to
be like it's standing in front of the
Eiffel Tower or something but then you
need to know the distance and they know
the distance that yeah but I don't think
just compare yeah I don't know yeah rule
is easier isn't it
anyway anyway we're getting off we get
off track so men like when they the
question is so important to them that I
think one things they ask that is like
there's almost like men don't want to
face the moment of truth like it would
be easy to just measure but they're like
is there another way to find the answer
because there's so much insecurity I
guess and fear and anxiety around the
process have you seen on South Park
episodes where they do that where they
do what they measure their penis have
you seen this huh I haven't seen it
anyone who's listening if you get the
opportunity to go back and watch a South
Park episode where they all measure each
other's penises it's unbelievable
because they there's some people who
have really small measurements and they
all get really really angry so then they
create this new formula where they
adjust for the you're like the height of
the penis and then they divide it and
they create this ratio and it actually
makes it like several feet long and then
every all of the problems that everybody
had has been completely accounted for
these happen in sports I remember
like my friends I really nerdy but we
were like we were nerdy and very very
competitive it's like we get out the
stats at the end of the year I played
baseball and then like we'd all like
create that you know you have like the
basic stats like batting average your
home runs your RBIs your ron's whatever
and then we don't create metrics like
how we should weight the different
categories to kind of come up with
overall offense the kind of overall
production and we all came up with some
metric where we were ranked number one
that's the that's the adjusted penis
size
so um why why call it everybody lies
then why why was the book everybody but
yet first of all that my publisher chose
that title but I think it's a good title
it kind of gets the point some of my
research which is that people in their
day to day life lie a lot so live face
to face we also lie surprisingly
somewhat to anonymous survey it's that
sort of traditional way we tried to
understand human beings historically
what they're thinking what they're gonna
do what they have done why they do the
things they do is survey so Gallup Earp
you or Quinnipiac or and other
organization will ask people questions
and even with this methodology even
though it's anonymous people do shade
their answers to try to sound good maybe
they're lying to themselves maybe
they're just in the habit of lying they
don't have an incentive to tell the
truth so they are more likely to say
they voted in the previous election than
they did they did they exaggerate how
frequently they have sex if you ask them
in surveys you compare that to actual
condom sales I show in the book like it
doesn't correspond at all so you know
how what media they consume help replay
that they're watching kind of highbrow
stuff versus lowbrow stuff they all lie
in these surveys but now thanks the
internet and largely Google but other
websites as well we have kind of a new
window into people that I think gets cut
through the lies a lot so Google for
example you see people searching how to
vote where to vote that's really
predictive what they're actually no vote
you talk to see them search about
sexless marriage or sexless relationship
my boyfriend doesn't have sex with me
and then you get a kind of a more
realistic picture how when what happens
in many relationships and you have to
see people searching for their sexual
insecurity or you see people what they
actually want to read the media they
actually want to consume I think it's
really much more accurate you know and
then there's a whole section on
pornography I mean talk about an area
where there's been a huge amount of
deception because it's kind of there are
so many taboos in that area I think we
really do have unprecedented go into
people's kind of sexual sexuality know
that we've never had worry thanks to
pornography and I analyze in everybody
lies about the whole section where I
analyze just porn up what people
actually want we're not which make
people giggle but it's also I think
pretty fascinating and you're kind of
revolutionary kind of this window into
people's mind so we didn't have with I
mean you know you all of human history
up until five years ago we didn't know
that we didn't know what people
fantasized about sexually we might have
had some clues by you know novels people
wrote or some theories that some you
know people like Freud came up with or
you know there's some surveys the Kinsey
study but it's kind of a little bit know
there's questions on how accurate that
was by a sample but I think now we kind
of have really a much better lose in
that arena so kind of over and over
again I think so so there are just so
many areas where I think we do have on
press had incised to people yeah and
then it's your job to sift through this
aggregated anonymous data and try and
analyze of come up with some
correlations between things and some
interesting insights yeah yeah I think
that's kind of the talent there's kind
of art to data science I think data
science people kind of don't usually
associate with creativity we usually
think of art you know a painter is
creative a musician's creative a data
scientist we think is kind of this nerdy
just kind of sit by computer plug the
numbers in and I think creativity is a
huge part of data science otherwise you
kind of just drown in the data and you
don't really know what's interesting so
kind of the creativity is kind of
looking through all that and finding
those nuggets of wisdom you know the
how big is my penis search or the the
autumn of my other favors Indian then
the top Google search my husband wants
in India is my husband wants me to
breastfeed him and that's like anal yeah
yeah no I'm not joking that's like India
and nowhere else
and also breastfeeding porn is a
recently popular in India nowhere else
that's kind of the types of things that
I mean that's kind of like that's kind
of that kind of that's kind of shocking
in many ways cuz it's not talked about
it wasn't really acknowledged without
this data it kind of shows that some
sort of fetish can develop in one part
of the world and nowhere else and become
kind of somewhat widespread on think
it's you know the majority of Indian men
but it's certainly a large enough
significant minority yeah and already
without being talked about at all we
find about that right I'll else would
you know yeah yeah you wouldn't find out
about it without without this type of
data so that yeah so things like that I
mean you know kind of finding those
insights amidst you know just kind of
rows and rows of data it's kind of an
art and something that you get better at
with practice and takes a lot of
creativity one of the things that I
absolutely love pornhub
issue a bunch of stats at the end of
each year nothing they don't delve into
it like you do but it's like about
playtime the top search is by area and
and stuff like that and even that even
the things that they do in house is
pretty pretty powerful oh yeah and I
know some of the data scientists they're
in there they're really good and they're
and you know and it is just it's kind of
I kind of you know I think people don't
take it to almost seriously enough you
know in academia or sociologists I kind
of reached out to pornhub when I spread
my book and I'm like and I really want
to look at your data MIT explain to my
data scientists has showed them some of
the work I had done writing columns from
their times and they agreed to give me
the data but I I would have thought that
I'm like you get 10 emails a day from
like sex researchers or sociologists and
and and they're like kind of like no you
know you know they're kind of
comfortable with the methodologies
they've been using for 50 60 years and
you know the academic kind of slowly it
doesn't change
that that quickly and you know so it's
kind of I think I think your instinct in
my instinct is all that is like wow
that's fascinating like you know that
and you know relative to kind of just
another survey about human beings and
what they're doing what they're
interested in sexually actually seeing
kind of you know this data from this
enormous site of you know sexual fantasy
or sexual desire is pretty pretty wild
what happens when you receive the
pornhub stats in your Dropbox or like
over we transfer or whatever it is is it
just like this gargantuan kind of sticky
[Music]
a little bit like socially oblivious so
like for me it's just like I might as
well just be getting a dataset of like
interest rates historically or you know
inflation historically and running the
numbers on that to me I'm just except
this one was more interesting to me but
I'm not like oh there's a weird use of
my time or like a lot of people would be
kind of queasy looking at this or
embarrassing parents looking at this I
don't really whatever part of the brain
normal people have that kind of shot
Chai's away from that type of research
or that type of activity I definitely
you've I don't so how was it all found
the right industry to be in then yeah
well I kind of invented I think but yeah
it does fit my personality yeah if you
have like your kind of a little bit I
guess shameless and not Quizon I think
there's kind of a good combination which
is that I built off before I wrote my
book I built up all these credentials I
did a PhD in economics at Harvard and I
went to Stanford like philosophy I was
writer from there are times I worked at
Google so I think when I do this people
aren't like people are like give me like
a lot of leeway like if I was like some
20 year old in my bait like 20 year old
like with no no qualification I'm just
like hey you know I'm analyzing porn
every won't be like you know that burger
is like what was that guy doing boy like
from with me it's like oh you know this
is science
like I I think they're people assume a
certain perspective ility with me just
based on the credentials that I kind of
get away with you know
more than I then I otherwise would I
think you know if I didn't have the
credentials and I came out with the
research I did I think a lot of people
be like wait that guy just locked
himself in his apartment and watch porn
this is just him this is him and his
breastfeeding yeah with the credentials
it's kind of like oh that guy is no
exploring the deepest recesses of the
human psyche he's got this veneer of
like respectability an academic kind of
justification right yeah and invited to
like all these talks and like
prestigious places and it's never like
you know it's a you know which I I'm
kinda like did you did you freeze like
my book or like how filthy it is and how
inappropriate it is at times but okay
for some reason I just keep on getting
away with this prim and proper academics
everywhere and there's you just swimming
in pornhub statistics towards the stage
- let me say hello to everyone yeah I
talk I usually you know bring up some of
the boring data by trying I try again I
try to use the that once the
introduction comes and there's so much
respectability that it's kind of like
people gotta go look go up you know I
can kind of take them along on my ride
so good you know
so what else what else have we learned
from porn let's stay with porn for a
second before we get away from porn were
there any other sort of surprising
things that came up with mm I think when
I came to the book came out people said
they're really shocking to me I didn't
find this shocking so for example the
popularity of rape porn among women is
very very striking in data a huge
percent of heterosexual porn searches
for video videos watcher a woman are
perfect kind of violent humiliation
against the woman and much more popular
among women than men about twice as
popular among women than men that that
didn't shock me there have been surveys
that kind of have talked about that a
lot of women have these types of
fantasies and kind of just in my
conversations with friends I very honest
friends this is kind of you know because
this kind of come up in my life that
that it did it didn't when I when I saw
the data I like oh my god I'm shocked
like I don't it I mean look at look at
the most popular book of the last
yeah yeah yeah so right but you know it
still is it still did have I think what
was more interesting is you actually can
compare the percentages around the world
and it's not correlated all with how
women are treated that's kind of
interesting that's not it's not like all
so what you mean in other words so you
have like some areas like Berkeley
California or like parts of you know or
parts of you know or you have Sweden or
Finland turned ugly Finland now is a
female prime prime minister and like
that where there is really much
progressive attitudes towards women then
you have areas like you know Saudi
Arabia or Iran where women are really
held back and it's not like so you could
really rank kind of you know how women
are treated are they are they treat like
second class and how egalitarian is yeah
and you might you could imagine that
that could affect how women think about
themselves and kind of you know affect
their fantasies but it doesn't seem to
you know it is the universal universal
designer watch something hardcore pawn'
even if even if women are crawling up
telling you know saying they could be
everything they're equal to men they're
you know there still is that fantasy
seems to exist in about the same number
as the places where women are saying
like men should dominate you men are the
you know the the leaders should be the
leaders of society so that was pretty
interesting ties that is really really
fascinating do you ever ask the why
question do you ever bothered to delve
into that or do you just sort of stick
to the to the data so I've tried to in
the next in the next level you know I
think there are you know it's it's I
think the initial thing initially I was
kind of just presenting the facts and I
have I haven't made much progress I
thought other people would come up with
theory so I thought when I wrote the
breastfeeding one people are gonna like
maybe there's some explanation that's
very obvious you know I didn't know that
but nothing's come up you know to kind
of explain this so I don't know it's
it's tough I think you know I think
there are definitely some areas so
definitely I think people are more
attracted to people they grew up around
or like people like them I think
probably maybe more maybe because their
environment so there's time they've been
this long idea that opposites attract
and I think if you see in dating data
it's not true at all so in dating data
it's very very clear that people
are drawn to people who are similar
themselves on just about any dimension
you could measure and pornography data
it also seems to be the case so if you
look at areas that have high
african-american populations they tend
to watch porn
featuring african-american though so men
in that area those areas tend to watch
porn featuring african-american woman in
large numbers so it's not like you know
yeah I think you could imagine that it
would go the opposite way and the
fantasy of the black man would be you
know the the white cheerleader or
something I don't know that you could
have met but it it's definitely not the
case I thought that I kind of I think
also moves towards the Y direction that
maybe sexual I do think that one of the
things you see is that sexual fantasies
needs to be related to childhood in
various ways so people tend to have
fantasies from their childhood fantasize
about babysitter's or like teachers or I
think there's kind of a there's kind of
maybe kind of key moments in childhood
where people kind of get imprinted
sexually that also dovetails with some
other research and in fields of
sexuality that childhood imprinting is
really important in developing adult
sexuality that would explain why if you
know a black man had grown up around a
lot of black woman he probably moved
more likely to be attracted to black
woman that nothing had me clean up again
though what about um when we're talking
about the split between heterosexual and
homosexual there must be some
interesting insights there about how
many men and women are being truthful
about their sexuality yeah so one of the
things that's also strike naday which
also didn't surprise me just because it
had come up in conversations I've had
with great honest Francis the popularity
of lesbian porn among women who
otherwise consider themselves totally
straight and I think you know I like I
don't think that they're necessarily in
the closet so like I think about I think
I don't remember the exact numbers I
think someone like 20 to 25 percent of
pornography views from women or for
lesbian explicitly lesbian porn and I
think you know this has come up in
surveys or focus groups a lot of women
you know that they live in for
clear San Francisco or areas where it's
totally you know or a lot of where where
you know in this day and age I think
it's pretty okay to be lesbian I don't
think there are many social pressures to
be heterosexual and they consider
themselves straight they only want to
pursue relationships with men but
they're just like you know the female
bodies hotter like it's just they can I
think disconnect kind of the real
emotional women are maybe sometimes I
don't want to over generalize but women
may be better disconnecting the kind of
emotional romantic connection judges
that your your physical in interesting
ways possibly I don't know it's that's
good that's cut unique insight because I
doubt that the equivalent would be true
for men with yes gay porn yeah I see
with men is that gay porn is about five
percent you know depending on it depends
on the side you look if it seems like
about five percent of male porn maybe a
little bit lower is for gay porn and one
of the things you see is that it's a
it's it seems pretty clear you know it's
almost as high in areas where it's hard
to be gay where a lot of your men say
they're gay
it's a place like Mississippi or Alabama
or Tennessee if you ask men are you gay
only about one to two percent of men
will say they're gay whereas in New York
and California about four percent of men
will say they're gay but the gay porn
searches are almost the same everywhere
which I think says that that a lot of
the men in Mississippi are in the are in
the closet you know I do think you also
see with the searches so the number one
search neck like one of the top searches
right in the same session where someone
searches gay porn is gay test there's
all kind of ridiculous searches I think
I out they get my penis surgically
ridiculous questions to try to figure
out like are you gay
but I think and these searches are much
more accommodating in the place where
it's hard to be gay the gates as
searches and I think when you see these
these kind of search strings you kind of
see a tortured man a man who's really
uncomfortable with his sexuality and and
is trying to it's like trying to find
some way to prove that he's not gay you
know almost to himself is not proving it
to anything else right yeah there's some
some stupid Internet
test so I think did you see kind of the
torture that you know it that some gay
men feel in places where it is hard yeah
which is you know it's changing
thankfully a fewer and fewer parts of
the world now you have the anti-gay
attitudes but there still are a lot of
places yeah it's interesting now why are
you talking about these strings of
search terms where you can weave
together a narrative of what's going on
were there any other strings of search
terms that you thought were particularly
interesting or anything you've come
across recently yeah so one of them I've
been I'm working on article this now but
I've been looking at you know a dark
topic with suicide I think it's an
important topic because you could
imagine if you had a search string if
you had a string of searches and someone
searches how to commit suicide you could
imagine looking at the searches for a
year and kind of getting of you of
what's causing them to have that thought
I think that's another area or we don't
have right now a great idea of why
everybody you know why people think of
suicide because there's so much stigma
around that whole area and what like one
of the things I found which is really
surprising was a calm a somewhat common
cause of suicidal thought among young
people is herpes getting diagnosed with
herpes the STD which kind of sounds a
little ridiculous it's not a it's a ZZZ
actually pretty common and it's it's not
one with you know it's not
life-threatening the physical symptoms
are to the best of my knowledge are
fairly limited but I think the stigma is
immense and you can imagine but you know
a young person who's just gotten
diagnosed with herpes when when people
are eighteen nineteen years old I mean I
applied go back to my own experience in
that age group you don't know what's
going on you don't know how the world
works it's such an a time of extreme
paranoia that there's something
fundamentally wrong with you I'm it's
kind of like the kids in Mississippi or
searching gay porn and gay tests there's
it's so easy to get paranoid that you
are kind of
you know lacking in some fundamental way
or you know you not you don't know
what's common what is in common I've
heard stories of you know woman the
little girls will freak out when they
first grow breasts that they have breast
cancer or something like you know it's
like when you're a kid and when you're I
think the possibility for a kind of
extreme paranoia is very high and it can
make this the data says it can lead you
to be sitting so much pain and so much
anxiety that you actually I think of
commit suicide so I think that's really
a promising area of research to kind of
get in the mindset of the suicidal
particularly young people and feeling
suet and maybe starting to fight these
out it's just another thing I found is
the number one search wendy in the
search string when people search herpes
and how to commit suicide is celebrities
with herpes which is they're basically
looking for role model it's actually
that's actually a common search for just
about any illness so people who have
depression search celebrities with
depression people have back pains or
celebrities with back pain leave all are
looking for role models for heroes of
theirs who share their condition so that
they feel less stigmatized and I looked
on Google what kind of happens when you
search liberties with herpes
and if you search celebrities with just
about any illness celebrity depression
huge number of celebrities openly
discuss their depression in part to
fight the stigma celebrities with with
back pain celebrities with and just on
any illness you think of a long list of
celebrities saying they're said kind of
coming out like that closet that to hell
I think to their credit to help their
fans who might also be struggling with
this problem with celebrity with herpes
you see all basically the top sites at
least last time I checked was just
celebrities denying they had this you
know it's the opposite
yeah then you can imagine all right like
put all this data together you have
young people they figured I know this
herpes they're thinking of committing
suicide they're looking for a
celebrity's with herpes instead of Greek
you know getting created with a list of
celebrities videos saying you know this
is nothing to be ashamed of it's not a
big deal I live with this you know
you have celebrity saying I would never
have you know yeah it's kind of like it
kind of every time I tell us it does
make me giggle you know I admit I've
giggled sometimes myself I think it
actually is like kind of profound and
and serious and shows the power this
kind of unvarnished window into the
human mind and how powerful that could
be and you know that a lot of people a
lot of people are suffering in ways that
it makes us giggle because they're so
silly but to that person it's not silly
it's like they might as well be in
Auschwitz like they might like the pain
that someone a suicidal person is
feeling no matter what the cause of it
is extreme so you know like so I think
getting a sense of getting is getting a
sense of a better sense of the people's
kind of darker thoughts can be really
helpful in kind of Kent you know then
that kind of we kind of have that kind
of suggests I'm an obvious way to change
it get more celebrities to stay in it to
kind of you know say they have herpes
I'm not sure I'm not quite sure how you
Monday for that but yeah you're right
the social I don't know you'd say the
social policy implications the welfare
implications the advertising role model
the everything that is the downstream
from this you know third order fourth
order fifth order effect that of us
realizing this super super profound I
hope you know we're only halfway through
this but one of the things that's
certainly coming to mind at the moment
for me is that you're right what you've
done so far with your first book is kind
of just laid out the facts right this is
this this is what it is that's the
surface level of the permafrost right
but the roots underneath that's the job
of a lot of people several orders of
magnitude more people than a guy with
with a our code and a Google Doc like
yeah yeah all right there are there are
a lots of people in this area and you
know data science is just exploding in
all kinds of ways and I think a lot of
people are you know I think definitely
Millennials or people younger than
Millennials are also looking you know it
seems like the values are shifting
little bit where it's less about just
making money so I think initially
everyone's kind of like OData sighing
it's that's a lucrative field I can get
a job at you know sending more people to
click on ads or work get a job in
finance which it just told our total you
find jobs and lo and behold the swimming
through pornhub date of five years after
the fan to me that they're you know that
they're kind of bored of studying you
know they they get there and they like
data science but they're kind of bored
of getting people to click on the ads
and they're you know they feel kind of
unfulfilled and lacking purpose and I
think there are ways to use this data
towards social good as well good but
what what's your so we're in 2020 you
just crossed the threshold into the year
of the presidential election in America
I mean this this must be like you
staring down the barrel of the Super
Bowl for your your industry or is it
just gonna have inundated with loads of
different types of Statistics and then
you can measure them before and look at
what happens afterwards have you got
some plans for this yeah and I play
around every election there are
definitely insights in the internet I
think nate silver of 538 does a really
good job of making predictions based on
kind of all the data so it can be hard
to be you know tough to beat his
predictions you know he put he put so
much thought and care it to didn't mean
I'm guilty
did you retweet something of his about
was it the Democratic nominees was that
like this yeah yeah yeah yeah I did well
he just built a model of the Democratic
nominee and I just thought that this
wasn't based on data there's actually
just based on my intuition that he's
maybe under estimating Michael
Bloomberg's chances just because you
know he's his whole he kind of in the
past models the past elections where
he's building the models from there's
never been Kenseth who was willing to
just spend billions of dollars to try to
get elected so I think we don't really
know how that's gonna play out and then
kind of you know makes me say he
shouldn't you know I think in his model
doing works at 1% or something like that
and I kind of think you know maybe five
to ten percent just because the amount
of resources is going to throw at this
problem going you what's the have you
looked at much data I don't know whether
you can predict this far out but if you
looked at much data from
fold into 2020 I think it's not I think
that this time out this this part this
time out it this far out it's tough you
need you need to look closer I think so
many people just aren't really thinking
about their election or you know a lot
of it a lot of the general election will
come down to who's gonna actually turn
out to vote and that I we're gonna need
to wait you know if you weeks before the
election we will really get clues and
who's actually gonna turn out to vote
you hear the story that people decide as
they cross the threshold into the voting
booth right like it's like the decision
that they actually feel like they make
is that but it must be so interesting to
to compare because you have exit polls
that don't you know in the last election
that you guys had the exit polls didn't
marry up tremendously well with what
actually happened but were you did you
have better more of an insight about
what was going to go on or
retrospectively would I I said Trump was
gonna win but I don't know if that's cuz
I'm a genius or a pessimist because I'm
just always let's go with genius okay
yes I'm always predicting horrible
things are gonna happen but there there
are some close so on the interesting
things that correlates with voting
outcome is the order you put candidates
and searches so a lot of people they
search Trump Clinton polls or Clinton
Trump polls or trauma Clinton from
collection you can see if you actually
look historically the order if people
put Trump Clinton first they're much
more likely to go Trump they put Clinton
Trump for Clinton Trump Clinton first a
more like Bill Clinton and that's kind
of interesting because it might almost
be subconscious and you could imagine
someone like they've been searching
Trump Clinton election Trump Clinton
polls Trump Clinton debate and then they
say if you ask them they're undecided
and they go to the they go to the
polling place and they think you're
undecided then a few seconds before they
class their vote as you said they say
okay you know I'm feeling Trump well
maybe they weren't undecided all along
and if you like looked at the data they
were giving away subconsciously
which way they were gonna go have you
have you looked at much of some Horace's
work on free will I dunno I dunno I
dunno some of that work yeah yeah
there's some interesting stuff on that
about when they say
raise your left or right hand or like
pick a random city or whatever it might
be and if they put people into is it
fMRI is where they can kind of do brain
scans and stuff like that and they're
able to tell when someone made the
decision to do the thing they're going
to do before they do it and also before
they think that they realize when they
were going to decide to do it and that's
kind of this is like a more drawn out
version of that yeah that way I'm sure
it happens yeah I'm sure it's a pretty
widespread phenomenon yeah so this I'm
looking at some of the things that I
pulled out with a book can we can we
talk about um what what should you say
on the first day if you want a second oh
yeah well that's how I my study that's
study researchers they actually had
people tape they were in speak they're
people going through speed dates and had
people tape their dates like tape record
everything that was said and then after
the date it was heterosexual dates the
man and the woman said basically whether
they wanted to go on a second date so
they could actually correlate the words
said on the date with the probability
that both you liked the other person and
that the other person likes you hmm so
some of the things weren't that
surprising so for example if a woman
laughs and a man's jokes she's more
likely to like him to want to go on a
second date well known men to get a
woman to like them or they're supposed
to use words that show kind of support
and care so you could say things like
that must have been tough or that must
be tough or you know that sounds hard
that kind of increases the probability
that a woman likes you and then
sometimes people like get away again
subconsciously how they feel maybe not
so as approxi but if a woman use it what
are called Hedge words she says things
like maybe are kind then she's much less
likely to like the guy regardless of
what got off because maybe I like cheese
maybe I want to dessert do you want a
second day yeah kind of whatever it's
kind of like she's kind of giving away
that she's not excited about the guy and
saying those things that's pre
interesting and then the more a woman
talked about herself the more she likes
the guy and the more likely the guy is
to like her so like a good successful
date tends to have more more the woman
uses I or the more women use an i the
more likely it's a successful date from
both people's perspective so kind of the
Cauvery the conversation shifts towards
the woman's life that's a good a good
sign hmm I wonder if I wonder if Neil
Strauss could rewrite the game or could
do like the game 2.0 but just do off the
back of like big data analysis and I
think it's def is definitely promising
you know definitely a lot of these you
know I think yeah I think a lot of a lot
of the rules that people have come up
with you know some of them are probably
true some of them you find out the data
aren't true
so yeah it's interesting to have some of
this off I don't know whether you call
it like folklore or some of the stuff
that people posit about human nature
right like you have from Neil Strauss
just a guy that tries to teach someone
pickup art history with real-world
experience to a doctor who's got a
degree in psychiatry psychology or
philosophy or you know human behavior
behavioral economics whatever it might
be for the most part people are just
kind of creating these proxies or this
like closest justifiable reason for why
they think someone does something and
trying to link these two things together
and then there's you who's kind of just
got this x-ray screen that actually gets
to look at precisely what it is without
them being worried about signaling to a
researcher without them being worried
about coming back to haunt them at work
because they said that because they
agreed that they voted for some terrible
political party with bad views or
whatever it might be
it must be there'll be a lot of them
fields I think that might end up
becoming a ousted or like you know kind
of really really appended with some of
the things that big day it will come up
with well it's not just me but yeah it's
no don't bother you
his type of research is very powerful
tool you know sometimes it just
confirmed what people previously thought
again little that a woman laughs Adam
and joke that that means she likes him I
think that's one that we kind of figured
out without data analysis without tape
recording everybody's all that all these
dates and falling and mining the text
but there definitely are areas where I
think our intuition and our theories
have been wrong because they haven't
been based on data so what you said that
you working on a second book at the
moment what some of your research but
you know what have you been interested
in recently so my second book is on how
you can use data to make better life
decisions kind of going off this idea of
what you should say on a first date
partly based on part of the motivation
right book is that when I read the when
I what you can actually see now you can
get kind of data on what people what
registers with people as they read your
book because on Amazon Kindle you can
see the most underlined lines or the
highlights highlight function yeah I
like exactly so one of the things I
noticed is that people seem really
interested in ways they can improve
their own lives
which kind of fits the enterprise theme
because I think people don't necessarily
like to admit that as much people don't
particularly intellectuals the time
people would be drawn to my book like to
say they don't read for self-help they
read to learn more about the world or to
kind of help other people and I think
you definitely do see people want to
know what what can I say in a first date
how can I make more money you know when
should how come what business should I
start so based on that I'm basically
just catering to the masses and writing
a book on how you can use data better
life decision yeah you can use data to
work out what you should write in a book
to have another New York Times
bestseller yeah yeah I guess that's that
yeah I guess that's the motivation but
so I'm going through all the areas of
like parenting and dating and happiness
and Wow so of you have you elicited any
interesting insights into parenting or
happiness recently yeah well I mean I
think a lot of its researching other
people's data but we're talking about
other peels here that I don't think not
enough people know about but I'm real
fascinated by these people who do
happiness studies on dope you've heard
about this they ask people they ping
people different times of the day and
they ask them what they're doing and
their mood oh yeah yeah so I think
that's just kind of a really fascinating
window into human happiness that I think
hasn't been fully you know hasn't been
fully discussed so they're always kind
of interesting thing and they're like
some kind of interesting
counterintuitive things so for example
well when people are drinking alcohol
they get a big boost in happiness that's
not surprising so you got like three or
four points on a 100 point scale of
happiness if you're drinking alcohol but
one of the things that's interesting is
that we tech people tend to drink
alcohol when they're doing something
already fun so if they're doing if
they're socializing with their friends
or they're having sex then they tend to
drink alcohol but actually if you drink
alcohol then it only gives you a tiny
boost and happiness or no boost but if
you drink alcohol when you're doing
something boring which people like never
do or much less less likely to do then
you get a huge boost in happiness
so you actually like get a bigger if
you're like cleaning you know like a
cleaning up sweeping or the floor or
something or commuting to work you know
obviously there are reasons sometimes
not not to drink during these
opportunity but it's actually more
effective your happiness I think people
use alcohol to try to take a good
experience or a great experience and
make it epic which doesn't really work
instead of kind of kind of break
avoiding the doldrums kind of well right
yeah which is dangerous advice it's kind
of a path towards alcoholism so I want
to be very careful and like a lot of
people addicted to alcohol I don't it's
just just telling people to drink
anytime they're bored or unhappy isn't
necessary use caution but it is kind of
it is it does kind of show I think one
of the things I'm trying to show is ways
that we make we make counter into like
the ways that counterintuitive decisions
kind of things that don't feel right can
be right so it doesn't feel right when
you're having fun with friends you know
or you're doing something really fun you
really feel like if I have to start
drinking this is gonna take it this is
gonna take me to the next level and it
tends not to work out that way
you know so but yeah but but you know
you don't always think oh you know if I
have a beer - now when I'm doing
something you know just doing this for
the boring thing then I you know that
then it'll be just fine and fine enough
I'll be alright so that's kind of its
not really interesting it's it's so so
fascinating that it's a small proportion
of the enjoyment from typical drinking
activities come from the drinking and
most of it comes from the activities
yeah that's the pool the one the reasons
we think drinking with friends is so
much fun because drinking with friends
is so much fun but being sober with
friends also is so much fun so yeah so
we don't kind of distinguish that you
know that a lot of it the reason it's so
fun is because the activity and we could
just do it without it like racist thing
yeah like like you got a huge bump in
happiness if you drink while you're like
getting ready to go out rather than when
you actually go out like because that's
boring so like so maybe it's so like I
think people are sober when they're like
taking a shower and like getting dressed
and they go out and they start and they
have a few drinks oh maybe from a
happiness perspective you should have a
few drinks and have a drink in the
shower I kind of enjoy the getting
dressed act the you know the getting
dressed activity will be okay that now
taller bowler okay and then you go out
you show her off but then you're ready
having fun so it doesn't really matter
hmm
yeah it's levels out about happiness a
little bit more how about um parenting
what what cool stuff did you have you
found out about parenting name that data
tells us on parenting so one of the big
early studies on parenting this wasn't
yet necessarily big data but they found
that they kind of studied adopted and
adopted kids and they found that overall
the parents you have the place you grow
up like the household you're in doesn't
make a huge effect on your overall life
outcome so if that's pretty pretty small
so if you get adopted by this family
here that family there you tend to end
up pretty similar so it's not a huge
effect so it seems like the overall
effect of parenting and that huge but
then recently they found studies mining
huge amounts of people who have moved
kids who have moved during their
childhood and they found that the
neighborhood you grew up in if you move
to certain
neighborhoods you do way better so I
think if you put together these two
findings the overall effect of your
house isn't that big of the household
you grow up in isn't that big but the
neighborhood you live in is pretty big
it means that single effect of parenting
is where you raise your kids
so that has way bigger effect than
basically I argue everything else you do
as a parent compliant basically the
particular area you raise your kids and
one of the reasons for this is that role
models are really important for kids and
the role models aren't just you so so if
you see like girls who grew up in
neighborhoods with lots of female adult
female scientists are much more likely
to become scientists themselves they
kind of see they kind of see role models
african-american boys who grow up around
a lot of african-american males who are
successful stay married who have jobs
are much more likely to do it themselves
and it's not necessarily true their own
parents so kind of one of the things
kids kind of discount advice from their
parents frequently or rebel against
their parents so your parent you know if
you're an african-american boy your dad
leaves you you may just because you may
decide I'm gonna be the best parent ever
because I don't want to be like my
[ __ ] dad or your dad's a great dad
you're gonna you kind of repel the other
direction I can never live up to him so
it's kind of the parent relationship is
very complicated but the neighbor
relationship is not so complicated it's
kind of like if you have pool you're
black when you have a pool at good Rome
african-american role models on the
street that's unambiguously good so in
general kind of like the almost the best
way to parent is kind of just get a lot
of other people to do the job 3:02 you
know they're just gonna discount
anything you say but if you kind of
surround your kids with people who live
life the way you want your kids to end
up that will have a big impact and you
can see oh you can use this you can use
this finding kind of lots of ways kind
of any I think a parents try to lecture
their kids too much try to lecture their
kids and you know you got to do this you
got to do that I think a better way is
take one of your friends who they admire
to kind of tell them that where it's
more likely to kind of
they'll want to live up to it kind of
you utilize the fact that the I think
from the evidence that other people are
much more influential on your kid than
you are because again you you are
cutting your their relationship with you
is very complicated yeah it's so funny
that you can outsource parenting to the
Joneses next door and beyond right you
take you take our kids and I'll take ya
I'll take your kids and you be as good
as you can and I'll be as good as I can
and we'll just have that loads of elon
musk's and it means you've got I mean
you gotta be cautious and who you in the
Jones is you choose the particular Jones
is there you nonsense you chew it so you
can also have bad role models in the
area on you know that that they see a
guy who is just like is lazy all day and
just drinks all the time and seems to be
having a good time there's like oh I
want to be like yeah I want to be like
that yeah actually it's a cliche right
it's a cliche of the the parents that
spend several thousand tens of thousands
of pounds dollars per year sending their
kid to some super high-end private
school or they get them home tutored and
they've had you know they've tried to
give them all of the opportunities and
the head start in life or whatever it
might be and this kids in with like a
bad crowd and grows up to be you know
some drug dealer or also you know get in
trouble all the time always getting
kicked out of schools or whatever it
might be
despite the parents best efforts to try
and hide that you can't I think you can
I think what what the way I read the
evidence is you can mold your kids too
much because they can they can repel you
have to do it more subtly basically you
have to yeah yeah be more subtle and
putting them in situations without them
realizing it where they're you know the
kids have to want those outcomes the
outcomes that you want your kid you
can't tell them to want them they have
to want learn to want them themselves
that they're really gonna go to it cuz
they can be in the nicest school in the
world if their goal in life is just to
party and you know have fun and you know
not achieve academically or not work
hard then they're they'll just do that
you know no matter what you tell them to
are what schoolies on them but if you're
gonna somehow give you know give them
early on some people who they think are
really cool
who worked really hard and and you know
our you know our at achieve academically
then no want that in themself they'll
ask you to go to the private school
don't ask you to you know get a tutor
and that's gonna be really powerful you
know they the best thing you probably do
is trick them so they're like I want a
tutor and you're like well no if I can
afford it and then you finally you
eventually give in make it like they're
like make it they're fighting you two
yeah make it's like make it's a bit so
that they're kind of like like you're
holding back what they really want it
was actually a plan all along
yeah okay it was your yeah but don't let
don't let them realize that I think
that's more effective than saying you
have a tutor you got to be there you got
to play the piano you got to do this but
but again yet yeah the plan can work
it's just you gotta you know you know
like Oh somebody they think really cool
I was tutored as as a kid like that's
how I got really successful that's how I
got really hmm
and so that's how that's how I
eventually like did these things that
now you think are really cool yeah yeah
I've heard him I don't know whether this
is true but I remember hearing some
stories about where parents would treat
vegetables as kind of precious and as a
reward kind of like they do with sweets
to children and they'd managed to kind
of flip this sacrifice reward matrix on
its head
so that kids were like really clamoring
these the children were really clamoring
to get vegetables because of this basic
like I don't have it I want it yeah I
think that I think that that probably
yeah yeah I do that it's like that's
gonna be like finding out that Santa
Claus isn't real oh I'm sorry if
anyone's kids are watching I'm supposed
to put a warning on before I do stuff
like that if you are listening with your
children in the room I'm so sorry but
it's the same as that right like it's
like one day they'll grow up and they'll
be like 14 and realize hang on a second
vegetables weren't a treat all along but
I've been lied to for the last 14 years
of my life by these tyrants that I've
got as parents for that's man that's so
interesting I wouldn't have if any of
the listeners
think back to who their role models were
that were outside of their immediate
nuclear family maybe older brother or
maybe sorry outside the parent family
like older brother friends neighbors
whatever it might be I wonder if anyone
can try and work out where some of their
passions that they thought were
completely self created actually may
have come from I always want to be a
football coach well I mean three three
doors down was this professional
footballer or whatever it might be yeah
yeah yeah fast yeah yeah I'm trying to
think in my own experience I definitely
they decided someone with I want to be a
professional athlete I think that's just
from television but and that's also just
like a lot of a lot of people want to be
professional athletes I didn't live
necessarily near any professional
athletes but you know some some some
some dreams probably are just pretty
pretty standard but I definitely didn't
get an academic Drive that probably came
less from my parents and more from like
yeah I did see some people with like had
gone to these really good schools and
like kind of respect that I thought
they've got it from having gone really
good schools which there weren't a
number of people in my neighborhood who
had gone to know MIT or Harvard or
Stanford and they did have this respect
and I'm like oh I could have that
respect if I go to one of these schools
maybe it's if you know you're just
swimming in swimming in big school
diplomas and all different qualification
I think how I I think that was from
seeing that it because my parents didn't
go to like fancy schools or anything and
and but yeah I mean it
it's obviously complicated I'm your
parents also can you know sometimes be
of course a role model and a lot of
times kids do just follow in their
parents footsteps but I do think the
parent relationship relationship is
complicated and you know you do
frequently see kids rebelling against
other parent various ways where is
nobody again like the you know the the
friends or neighbors I think nobody at a
young age most most I think most people
think their friends and neighbors are
pretty cool or their friend's parents
are pretty cool yeah are in like oh I'm
gonna rebel against what that person did
or something yeah for sure
I'm
did you do some stuff on the stock
market as having a little bit of a look
did you look at the way that the stock
market moves in gaming the stock market
but I I didn't have too much success
it's pretty tough stock market is pretty
uh pretty chaotic and I think you know
one of the conclusions I come up my book
is that it's a lot easier to find
insights into like racism or child abuse
or abortion or at least other areas
because unfortunately there's not as
much talent trying to find those
insights as the stock market so the
stock market urine PDA against you know
astrophysicists and physics
everybody's trying to figure out the
stock market and you know so it's a
little bit of a you know a little bit
more challenge but yeah you can't you
can't trade racism on the open market
can you so yeah and yeah you can't get
rich finding a new map of racism the
United States you can get rich finding a
hidden inefficiency in the stock market
so I think there's definitely much more
talent towards the stock market that it
can it can be tough with public data as
I've historic used finding kind of an
insight what about you mentioned
abortions that there's the thing about
the back alley sort of emotion crisis
think you take us through that yeah well
I was just shocked by how frequently
people search on Google for
do-it-yourself abortions for kind of
giving yourself a miscarriage giving
yourself an abortion and these searches
are almost highly concentrated almost
perfectly if you look at where these
searches are almost perfectly map a
place where it's hard to get an abortion
and they've got they went off a lot in
2011 when it there was kind of a
crackdown the United States against
legal abortion so I think and also if
you actually look at the data it does
seem like they're missing pregnancies in
those areas so births basically births
have gone down a lot and abortions
having kind of of course abortions kind
of also gone down and you kind of do the
math it seems like probably there there
are there's kind of so missing and
happening someone hang on I think a lot
of that probably is off the books
abortion some of its not back
there are sadly people literally search
how to use a coat hanger to give
yourself an abortion but some of its
kind of abortion pills which now people
are getting online which some people say
it's actually a good thing some abortion
rights activists say it's actually a
good thing because they're pretty safe
and they're way for people who don't who
are in areas where it's hard to get a
legal abortion to kind of still have an
abortion without other control yeah yeah
it's not a huge Assessor necessarily but
don't you so most of what we've spoken
about today so far has been to do with
Google whether any of the platforms that
you were able to pull data from that you
could look up yeah or not as I talked
about I analyzed stormfront that's kind
of a white supremacist site also an
interesting data set that's a I analyzed
Wikipedia where successful people tend
to be born why do they live upon college
towns and cities mostly so and yeah
that's that's yeah I'm party that's how
the genetics they probably you know if
you're a kid of professors you're more
likely to be smart yourself and be more
like to be notable in various ways but I
think some of it is exposure to
innovation again both early exposure so
you see rock-and-roll stars are much
more likely to grow up in college towns
I think the part part the reason for
that is because college towns are kind
of places of musical innovation the REC
though they they historically it's not
change it within these kind of big
record stores that were kind of cutting
edge thought people would you know
really cool bad to come and play and
then good radio stations so I think part
of it the early exposure to innovation
go here and what about Facebook we've
got
got anything cool that you've realized
on Facebook recently that you pups take
from things I did is correct but I
looked at so Facebook you can measure
for basketball I looked at how many fans
everybody has on Facebook so I look for
basketball players basically how many
fans basketball players have I want to
see if how white thing white basketball
players compared to black basketball
players so historically it's been
thought that kind of white players get
kind of a boost in fandom and that a lot
of teams have thought - we thought that
a lot of teams hired like is their 12th
player they're their lowest bench player
a white guy just because the token why
done yeah token white guy because people
would be more like it though so you can
actually you can imagine building
analysis reading you know basically how
good every player is in basketball you
can control for all their stats so how
many points they score how many rebounds
they have I'm a assist they have etc
then you say like controlling for that
all else equal how many fans they have
on Facebook and what you see is that
African American players just have a
point the way more fans mostly due to a
huge bump up among African American a
little bump from everybody's they're a
little more popular among white people a
little more pocket among aging people a
little more popular among Hispanic
people and among African Americans is
just an enormous gain in fandom for you
know African Americans are much more
likely to support a black player who's
equally good as a white player then you
go the white player he's number 12 on
the bench he hasn't done anything and
he's got like 5 5 likes on his Facebook
page no no the normal yeah but but the
point is that if the black I hadn't done
anything he'd have 10 likes 1 pointed
the same player it seems like you know
again a contrary to some some historical
idea that there's kind of a racism bias
against black players in the NBA there
seems to be if anything a big s to black
players and building fanbase get you so
the final question that I wanted to ask
is actually one from Jordan who's part
of the modern wisdom project and he was
saying have your insights from big data
change your use of technology or
the only thing is like Google myself
Morgan a little bit of otherwise I think
and I really think there's made a big
change got you yeah it's one of the
things certainly this come up here is is
a a very interesting insight into human
nature into what it is that we do and
all the stuff like that but as you say
this anonymous aggregate data is
precisely that like it's happening but I
don't know that it's you as it's the guy
next door yeah yeah yeah yeah which is
interesting anyway one this has been
absolutely also if we got that we got a
date or an idea in mind about when the
the next book is gonna come up right one
at 21 but I'm not sure exactly when you
got to get through this presidential
election and then you're gonna have to
do all the view yeah yeah publish it
during the election because that ones we
focused on that election yeah I was
talking to a Paul bloom from Yale and it
was it was saying precisely the same
thing he's doing this new book about
suffering about how people really enjoy
suffering he'd managed to find a link
between BDSM and meditation which
actually sounds exactly like one of the
things that you would you would have
come up with out a big data and he was
saying he was like I think maybe be
finished like first drafts or to start
the year and blah blah blah and that's
all cool so we're gonna get it next year
news at now but it's an election this
year I'm not releasing anything so 2021
hopefully we'll get a load of new
literacies stuff through so um where can
people find you online so that they want
to follow stuff we're gonna go uh I just
googled set everybody lies nobody's
gonna remember my last name so just set
that realize then that they'll find you
know my Twitter everything else awesome
month thank you so much for I really
appreciate your time I'm gonna try and
work out who was I lived near at home
and
and see where the influence was on me
right cheers mama thank you so much
doing
[Music]